[Music]
in april 2003
the human genome project was declared
completed
putting an end to the 13-year long
scientific endeavor
what is the human genome project what is
inside the human genome
and how to sequence the human genome
these are some of the questions that we
will try to address in this lecture
the human genome project is an
international research effort to
sequence
and map all of the genes of homo sapiens
the project began in 1990 initially
headed by james watson at the u.s
national institutes of health
largely due to his disagreement with his
boss bernadine healy
over the issue of patenting genes he was
forced to resign in 1992.
he was replaced by francis collins in
april 1993
and the name of the center was changed
to the national human genome research
institute in 1997
a working draft of the genome was
released in 2000 and a complete one in
with further analysis still being
published
in may 2006 another milestone was passed
on the way to completion of the project
when the sequence of the last chromosome
was published in the journal nature
completed in april 2003 the human genome
project gave us a complete
representative sequence of the human
genome
the representative sequence is a
composite from several people who
donated blood samples
originally close to 100 people
volunteered to give a sample of their
blood
each person provided their informed
consent affirming that they agreed to
the study of their dna
no names were attached to the blood
samples and ultimately scientists used
only a few of them
these measures ensured that the dna
sequences remained anonymous
not even the donors knew whether their
samples were actually used or not
according the definition employed by the
international human genome project
the human genome was completed by the
end of 2003
however there are a number of regions of
the human genome that can be considered
unfinished
small gaps that are unrecoverable in any
current sequencing method remain
amounting for about one percent of the
gene-containing portion of the genome
these include the central regions of
each chromosome
known as centromeres which consists of
highly repetitive dna sequences that are
difficult to sequence
the centromeres are millions possibly
tens of millions of base pairs long
the ends of the chromosomes called
telomeres are also highly repetitive
there are also several loci in each
individual's genome that contain
repetitive sequence that are difficult
to sequence
other than these regions 99 of the human
genome sequence has been completed
however understanding the functions of
all the genes and their regulation is
far from complete
the rules of junk dna the evolution of
the genome
the differences between individuals and
many other questions are still the
subject of intense interest by
laboratories all over the world
the strategy originally established by
the publicly funded human genome project
was based on a method called
hierarchical shotgun sequencing method
in this approach genomic dna is cut into
pieces of about 150 megabases and
inserted into a bacterial artificial
chromosomes vector
and transformed into e coli where they
are replicated and stored
the bacterial artificial chromosomes
inserts were isolated and mapped to
determine the order of each cloned 150
megabases fragment
this is referred to as the golden tiling
path
each bacterial artificial chromosomes
fragment in the golden path
is fragmented randomly into smaller
pieces typically one to two kilo bases
long
and each piece is cloned into a plasmid
vector
the resulting transformed bacterial
colonies are picked at random and
sequenced on both strands
these sequences are aligned so that
identical sequences are overlapping
these contiguous pieces are then
assembled into finished sequence once
each strand has been sequenced about
four times
the term contig refers to a known dna
sequence that is contiguous and lacks
[Music]
gaps
in 1998 a parallel project was conducted
by the private company celera genomics
celera used a riskier technique called
whole genome shotgun sequencing which
had been used to sequence bacterial
genomes that smaller in size
and contain less repetitive dna shotgun
sequencing randomly shears genomic dna
into small pieces which are cloned into
plasmids and sequenced on both strands
thus eliminating the bacterial
artificial chromosomes step from the
publicly funded human genome project
approach
once the sequences are obtained they are
aligned and assembled into finished
sequence
the advantage to the hierarchical
approach is sequencers are less likely
to make mistakes when assembling the
shotgun fragments into contigs as long
as full chromosomes
the reason is that the chromosomal
location for each bacterial artificial
chromosomes is known
and there are fewer random pieces to
assemble
the disadvantage to this method is time
and expense
the whole genome shotgun method used by
solera genomics is faster
and less expensive but it is more prone
to errors due to incorrect assembly of
finished sequence
it also required tremendous
computational power
which method is better it depends on the
size and complexity of the genome
with the human genome each group
believes its approach to be superior to
the other
it is worth mentioning that cellera had
access to the publicly funded human
genome consortium data
but the human genome consortium did not
have access to the cellera data
indeed without the golden tiling path
released by the human genome consortium
the whole genome shotgun method will not
be able to determine where the fragment
of the sequenced dna belongs to
because of the advantages and
disadvantages of both approaches
an idealized strategy evolved into
hybrids towards the end of the project
in which the human genome consortium
selected more clones arbitrarily
and solera made use of the bacterial
artificial chromosomes maps and sequence
generated by the human genome project
in that way both organizations were able
to reach their goals in less than the
expected time frame
the total estimated size of the human
genome is 3.2 gigabases
most dna in the human genome is
non-coding dna
including intergenic regions introns
repetitive sequences and so forth
about 28 percent of human dna is
transcribed into rna
and only a mere 1.25 percent is actually
codes for proteins
on average the introns are longer in
human dna than in other organisms
sequenced so far
over half the human genome consists of
repeated sequences
some 45 percent is transposons
three percent of the human genome
consists of repeats of just a few bases
such as microsatellites variable number
tandem repeats and etc
and five percent of the human genome is
made up of duplications of large genome
segments
there are both at-rich regions in gc
rich regions in the human genome
curiously the zones of gc rich sequence
have a higher density of genes
and the introns are shorter the
significance of this is still unknown
one of the biggest surprise in the human
genome is the revelation that humans
only have around
25 thousand genes rather than the
previously estimated one hundred
thousand genes
the nematode worm center of ditus with
approximately eighteen thousand genes
has half as much genetic information as
humans
the mouse have essentially the same
number of genes as humans
thus the genome size is not directly
related to its biological complexity
another surprise of the human genome is
that only a third of the genome code for
protein
the other two thirds are dna that we are
yet to find out what their function is
these findings have significant
implications on how we understand the
basic science of how life works
but also how those sequences which are
regulatory
can affect health and disease
however biological complexity may
presence in the expressed protein
first alternative splicing of a pre-mrna
can yield multiple
functional mrnas corresponding to a
particular gene
in human about 60 percent of the
transcript are subject to alternative
splicing
second variations in the
post-translational modification of some
proteins may produce
functional differences for example 80 to
90 percent of human proteins are
acetylated
reversible phosphorylation of proteins
is another important regulatory
mechanism
reversible phosphorylation results in a
conformational change in the structure
in many enzymes and receptors
causing them to become activated or
deactivated
finally qualitative differences in the
interactions between
proteins and their integration into
pathways may contribute significantly to
the differences in biological complexity
among organisms
for example signals from the exterior of
a cell are mediated to the inside of
that cell by protein protein
interactions of the signaling molecules
this process
called signal transduction plays a
fundamental role in many biological
processes
and in many diseases proteins might
interact for a long time to form part of
a protein complex
a protein may be carrying another
protein or a protein may interact
briefly with another protein just to
modify it
therefore protein-protein interactions
are of central importance for virtually
every process in a living cell
although the human genome project is
considered completed
there are great challenges to understand
what it means
there is still one percent of the genome
at the heterochromatin region
unsequenced which may or may not harbor
any gene
this challenge will only be overcome by
the development of new sequencing
technique
also the regulatory signals for most
genes remain
uncharacterized it is currently unclear
how epigenetic modifications
such as cytosine methylation and gene
silencing on a genome-wide scale
determine their biological consequences
the human genome sequence also
identified more than 1.4 million single
nucleotide polymorphisms
although any two unrelated people share
about 99.9 percent of their dna sequence
some people may have an a at a
particular site on a chromosome while
others have a g instead
further work is currently being
conducted to find genetic variants
affecting health
disease and response to drugs and
environmental factors
the scientific challenge is outlined
above focus on how the genome sequence
can be mined for biological information
ultimately it is the function of the
gene product that plays the integral
role in the biological system
therefore tremendous effort has also
been carried out to decipher the gene
function
in summary the availability of a
complete genome sequence will enormously
facilitate the solution of the more
difficult problem of identifying the
genetic components of the more complex
and more common disorders such as many
forms of diabetes
asthma cancer and mental illness
in which multiple genetic and
environmental factors interact
using techniques that can measure the
expression of thousands of genes at a
time
scientists are now beginning to look
globally for differences in gene
expression that are associated with the
ability to respond to different drugs or
pathological states
such as cancer
you